بما يعني انه في اموال استمرت في التدفق
من الاتحاد الاوروبي على روسيا رغم
العقوبات هذه الاموال كيف تم انفاقها في
اي قطاعات وهل نتوقع استمرار هذا التدفق
الامر من جانبين اولا ان الاموال التي
كسبتها روسيا من تصدير السلعه الى اوروبا
خاصه النفط والغاز والفحم وماده اخرى
كلها فرضت عليه جدا لانه ربك كان عليها
تتكيفت فيما يخص ايجاد المصادر فمثلا في
المعاضي روسيا كسبت حوالي
280 مليار دولار
مقارنه ب 190 في العام الذي قبله وكثير من
ذلك من اوروبا
ساعد في دعم الاقتصاد وهذه باتت من
المسائل التي اصبحت سريه فلا يعطون
معلومات حول اين انطقت هذه الاموال الكثير
منها بالتاكيد على الدعم العسكري وهذا امر
واضح وحتمي ولكن ايضا
الكثير منهم ايضا الى الدعم للوظائف في
بعض المجالات لدعم البرامج الاجتماعيه مثل
الرعايه الصحيه والخدمات العامه التي
تحاول الدول الحفاظ عليها وهذا وهذا
ستانخفض لان الحكومه يجب ان تكون اكثر
حذرا فيما يخص الانفاق لانها لن تكسب نفس
الاموال في العام الماضي المجال الاخر
المثير حيث عادت الاموال او دخلت الى
روسيا هي
ليست من الاوروبينا والغربيين الذين
يستثمرون بروسيا بل الاعمال تملكها
الروسيه اوغاركيه
في روسيا الذين كسبوا اموالا طائله خلال
23 عاما الماضيه
والذين استثمروا
اموالا طائله خارج اوروبا في اوروبا وفي
الولايات المتحده وقد اعادوا هذه الاموال
بسبب العقوبات ولانهم غير قادرين على
استثمارات في اوروبا او دول اخرى فالكثير
من الاموال التي عادت الى روسيا في العام
الماضي كانت اموال روسيا عادت الى الوطن
وهذا الشيء بالتاكيد يناسب الرئيس بوتا
لانه تحدثا عن هذا الامر ذو عقدين
وقال هي عاده الاموال من الخارج وحاول حتى
حول الاشخاص الاستثماري
بالاموال الروسيه داخل روسيا بدلا من
الدول الاخرى ولكنه لم يحقق نجاح في تلك
العوام لغايه فبراير من العام الماضي ومع
بادئ العقوبات والان لاحظنا ان الاشخاص
ارغموا على اعاده اموالهم الى روسيا والان
يسعون لاستثمارها في روسيا فهي
الديناميكيه مثيره وسنرى كيف يتحقق
التوازن في كل ذلك فمن جهه هنالك انخفاض
كبير في الاستثمارات الاجنبيه والغربيه في
روسيا وسيستمر ذلك ومن جهه اخرى هنالك
اموال روسيه طائله عادت الى روسيا وسيسعون
لاستثمارها
الاقتصاد
فديناميكيه مثيرا والى الان لا نعرف
النتائج